JONATHAN: Good morning,
welcome to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Massachussetts.
Today it is my great pleasure
to welcome Donald Sull.
Donald joins us to talk about
his newest book co-authored
with Kathleen M.
Eisenhardt-- "Simple Rules:
How to Thrive in
a Complex World."
The book authors
challenge how we
think about complexity and for
new insights into how to cope.
They take us on
a surprising tour
of what the simple rules
are, where they come from,
and why they work, illustrating
six kinds of rules that really
matter, drawing on
rigorous research
and using entertaining
stories, they
find insights in
unexpected places
and offer fresh information
and practical tips
on fixing old rules
and learning new ones.
Now we can settle in
and get comfortable
because the next
portion of our hour
will be devoted to
summarizing Don's CV.
He is a global expert on
strategy and execution
in turbulent markets.
He is a senior lecturer at
the Sloan School at MIT,
having previously taught at
Harvard and London Business
School, winning teaching
awards at both institutions.
He has published five books, 10
best-selling "Harvard Business
Review" articles and
over 100 case studies
articles and chapters on
strategy and execution
in turbulent markets.
"The Economist" identified
his theory of active inertia
as an idea that shaped
business management
over the past century.
And "Fortune" has listed him
as one of the 10 new management
gurus.
Please join me in
welcoming Donald Sull.
[APPLAUSE]
DONALD SULL: Thank you, Jonathan
for that kind introduction.
I cringe every time I hear
that word guru, by the way.
As Peter Drucker, the only
management thinker who actually
deserved the title guru, once
said that journalists only
use the guru only
because they were
too lazy to go to the
dictionary remind themselves
how to spell charlatan.
So I appreciate
the introduction.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is the book that my
co-author, Kathy and I just
published about six weeks ago.
It's called "Simple Rules."
This is Kathy on
your right here.
Kathy is a professor at the
engineering school at Stanford.
And we started this
project about 15 years ago
with a very narrowly
defined research agenda,
which was we're really
interested in how
technology intensive companies
mainly based in Silicon Valley
managed the complexity
of their ecosystems,
their technological systems,
their competitive domains.
And so we started
a little study just
to dig into that
specific question.
And what we found-- had
a big finding out of
that preliminary research--
was that the companies that
were more successful
be they start ups,
you know, or startup-ish,
at that time, eBay and Yahoo
at the time or bigger
companies even then like Cisco,
the companies that were
more successful in dealing
with complexity had a systematic
bias towards simplicity.
And specifically
what they did was
they'd identify a critical
activity in the firm.
It might be a new product
development, partnership,
merger and acquisition
activity, and apply
a handful of simple rules
that provided some guidance
to that process but left scope
for flexibility, innovation,
creativity, human judgment.
So this was the big finding
out of that research.
And over the past 15
years, Kathy and I
together with our doctoral
students, with our research
teams, have looked at simple
rules in a variety of domains
and then expanded our study to
look more broadly into domains
outside of business
and innovation
where we focused to see
how simple rules are used.
And so we think this is
the first study that's
looked at-- a lot of people
have looked at simple rules
in specific domains.
So in monetary
policy, for instance,
there's a rich body of research
about the role of simple rules.
And social biology--
rich body of research
about the role of simple rules.
So we think we're the-- this
is the first project that's
looked at these
different domains
and tried to draw
cross-cutting lessons about why
simple rules work, what the
boundary conditions are,
when they work and don't work
so well, and in particular
how to develop them so
that they're effective.
So that's what we'll
talk about today.
I actually discovered
the power of simple rules
long before we started
this research project.
So when I was an undergraduate,
I went to Harvard.
And I worked through college.
And one of the jobs I had
was as a doorman at a bar
called Jack's, which all of
you are too young to remember.
You remember Jack's?
Oh, excellent, excellent!
Excellent, all right, my man.
That is great news.
OK, so for the rest of you--
AUDIENCE: I think
I saw the fire.
DONALD SULL: Oh, no, you're
kidding me, oh, jeez.
So yeah, that's kind of
the sad end to the story.
So Jack's was this bar on Mass.
Ave almost exactly halfway
between Harvard and MIT.
So when I tell most
people, maybe not you
guys-- certainly
not you-- when I
tell most people
I worked at a bar
halfway between Harvard and
MIT, this is what they picture.
Right?
It's like the "Big Bang Theory."
You've got some
doctoral students
in there talking through
their dissertations
or undergrads going
through their problem sets.
But Jack's was not this bar.
When you think
Jack's, I don't want
you to think "Big Bang Theory."
I want you to think
"Sons of Anarchy."
So Jack's had two
design criterion
that attracted the local biker
gang, which was called the Rum
Pot Rustlers.
And the Rum Pot Rustlers, what
they loved about Jacks, one,
we had a live band every night.
And they were pretty good
bands-- Mighty Bosstones
and Til Tuesday.
They were big, local bands.
So they could drink.
They could listen to the band.
The other thing was instead
of a wall overlooking Mass.
Ave, it was all
plate glass windows.
So why does that matter
if you're a biker.
No, don't tell them.
AUDIENCE: You can
see your motorcycle.
DONALD SULL: Exactly.
So it turns out
Jack's allowed you
to do the three things you
loved to do most in life, which
was drink, listen,
to rock music,
and make sure your bike was OK.
So this is pretty
much biker Valhalla.
And just to give you a sense--
this was kind of a tough crowd.
These guys had
nicknames like Shotgun,
Man Mountain, Mother
Killer, like don't ask.
You really don't want
to know the back story
to these nicknames.
So, anyway, that's
where I worked.
And by the way, the question
you should be asking
is why were you working as
a bouncer in a biker bar?
I'm sure I'm built for a sport.
I'm sure that
sport is badminton.
But the thing was the
owner, this guy Ben,
he had graduated from Harvard
and he hired all the bouncers
from the Harvard hockey team
and the Harvard Boxing Club.
And I boxed all through, as a
young man, boxing was my sport.
So anyway, I quickly
discovered after my second trip
to the emergency room in
the first month on the job,
that a pure brawn strategy as
a middleweight bouncer in a bar
full heavyweights was a
non-winning proposition.
This was just-- this was not
working out according to plan.
But the money was great.
And it was a terrific
job and a lot of fun.
Anyway, so what I did
was-- as I was recovering
from my concussion and
only slightly disoriented
by that time, I came up
with a set of simple rules
for being an undersized
bouncer in a biker bar.
And I'll just tell
you what those rules
are because they illustrate
the characteristics
of effective rules.
So the first one was don't
let trouble in the door.
So it turns out it is
an order of magnitude
harder to throw a knucklehead
out of the door than to keep
said knucklehead from entering
the door in the first place.
So I'd just say no.
And they'd yell, they'd
shout, they'd get angry,
and then they'd leave.
So that was quite helpful.
The second rule was
sober beats drunk.
So people think when you're
drunk, you're better fighter.
You're more prone to fight.
But you're sloppy.
Your reflexes are slow.
So I had a hard and
fast rule that I
didn't start drinking
until after the bar closed,
which frankly, might have
been club policy anyway.
I think at minimum,
it was encouraged
by management-- that behavior.
So it turns out
empirically I noticed
that certain types
of bands always
had these complete rock heads,
usually from South Boston, who
came in and caused big trouble.
So I'd just get the
manager to always double up
on doormen when those
bands were playing
so we had a little support.
And then by far the
most helpful rule
was number four, which is
keep bikers on your side.
Listen, if you're dealing
with a group of people
with nicknames like
Shotgun and Mother Killer,
common sense dictates
you do not annoy them.
That is just like anybody
configure that out.
But I went beyond that.
So I tried to cultivate,
maybe not a friendship,
but a cordial relationship
with these guys.
So they went out to
conduct their business,
I'd watch their bikes.
I went to get pizza,
I'd buy them pizza.
Their friends came
to the door, I'd
let them in the door,
which came in very handy
in the following situation.
So it was Friday night,
and the bar is rocking,
and we're having a great time.
And I look over and here
are four knuckleheads
and, of course, they
are from Southie.
And the testosterone is flying,
and the chests are pounding.
And I'm like, oh,
god, not another trip
the emergency room.
So I'd walk over to the bar.
I'd always walk over to
the same guy, Man Mountain.
So Man Mountain is 6'
7"-- huge, bushy beard.
This was not an
ironic nickname is
the point I'm trying to make--
huge, bushy beard, big guy,
prison tats up
and down the arms.
And he only ever wore a vest,
never a shirt underneath,
never jacket over through the
depths of a Boston winter.
You guys have all lived
through a Boston winter.
So imagine riding
a Harley down Mass.
Ave in a winter like
this with only a vest on.
So the point I'm trying to make
is he was big, he was mean,
and he had a high
tolerance for pain.
So I said, Man Mountain would
you come with me for a minute.
He was like, yeah, sure.
So we walk over and walk
over to these knuckleheads.
And they're like, whoa, pounding
their chest and so forth.
And I was like, guys,
we've got two options.
Option one, you leave right now.
We're not going anywhere.
So, OK, fine, just listen to
what's behind door number two.
Option two is I introduce you
to my friend, Man Mountain.
And it never failed.
They just look at him
like, whoa, meekly put
down their glass, apologize.
So sorry to disturb
you, really, we're
just leaving now,
anyway, time to get back.
So it turns out these
four rules illustrate
what Kathy and I have
discovered are the defining
characteristics of
effective simple rules
across a wide
variety of domains.
So the first is
that the rules are
limited to a handful,
typically three to five.
Why would that matter?
What do folks think?
Why would the number
of rules matter?
AUDIENCE: You need to remember.
DONALD SULL: OK, first of all.
And it turns out some of you
may have learned at some point
that people can remember
seven, plus or minus
two, items in a category
ungarbled without prompting.
That's not true.
It turns out psychologists
have established
that we can remember
4 plus or minus
1 items in a single category
consistently ungarbled
without prompting.
So right, you remember them.
And, particularly, in the
heat of battle, it's helpful.
What else would matter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Combinatorial
explosion.
Rules that are interacting
with each other.
DONALD SULL: Exactly,
so part of the thing
is you get these long
laundry lists of rules.
There's all sorts of
interaction, some of which,
by the way, can be conflicting
interactions, which make it
very difficult to make choices.
So this at least surfaces
any conflicts in the rules
because you have a small
number you can kind of stare
at the same point.
What else would matter
about the number of rules?
It forces a prioritization.
OK?
So in many situations, at
least the situations where
simple rules work
well, there will
be a small number
of guidelines that
are most effective for the
most highest number of cases.
There'll be a lot of
idiosyncratic cases
that you don't want to
write a specific rule for.
So it forces prioritization.
The second defining
characteristic
is that they're tailored
to a specific activity.
So what we are not talking
about is broad principles
like be innovative and
respect human dignity--
terrific things, you
know, great values.
But any time you
have a set of rules
that are meant to apply
across multiple activities
or decisions in
order to encompass
these multiple
activities or decisions,
you need to achieve such
a level of abstractness
that they often
border on platitudes.
So we're always talking about a
specific activity or decision.
And in this case, it was
working the door at Jack's.
I have sometimes wondered,
I must say, like,
what would have
happened had I used
those rules in a different
activity like my school work,
for instance.
So I go into office hours
and say to my professor,
oh, how am I doing in class?
Very poorly, C plus.
Oh, really?
C plus?
Have I introduced
you to Man Mountain?
It's what we call a
conversation starter in academia
but focused on a single
activity, typically.
And then the third thing
is that simple rules are
a framework, not an algorithm.
And what we mean by
that is, and I know you
guys know a lot
about algorithms.
So this is a loose use
of the term algorithm.
The point we're trying
to make with this
is that it's a framework
for discussion.
It provides some guidance
for discussion and decisions,
but isn't something where you
put the input, turn the handle,
and the answer pops out.
It's not a replacement
for guidance or discretion
or judgment.
It is a guide and
framework for that.
And as we go and talk
through some examples,
I think that point will
become a little clearer.
So in the Jack's case,
I didn't define trouble.
There weren't a set
of-- there wasn't
a checklist of these are the
characteristics of trouble.
But it framed what I was looking
for when I went to the door.
So that's the defining
characteristics
of simple rules.
And one of the things that
we discovered, and again, we
had no clue of this when we
began this research project
was how widespread
simple rules are
across very diverse domains.
So The White
Stripes-- I don't know
if we have White Stripes
fans in the room?
OK.
So The White
Stripes-- Jack White
is a huge proponent
of using simple rules
every time he cuts an album
to constrain his creativity
and channel it in a
specific direction.
The medieval, or actually
the Renaissance Jesuits,
St. Ignatius of Loyola
used a set of simple rules
that guided the
selection of ministries
that the Jesuits pursued, which
allowed for explosive growth.
They were the Google
of the 16th century
explosive global
growth, pursuing
a lot of innovative
opportunities in their domain.
Japanese scientists have
studied the simple rules
used by slime mold as they
search for food to inform
their design of the Japanese
rail system, widely used
in sociobiology.
We'll talk about some examples.
So one of the things we
didn't know at the time
we started this,
but what maintain
our interest in this project
was how widespread simple rules
are.
And in the book, we give
some of these examples
to illustrate points.
So why simple rules?
We waited 15 years.
Why not wait another 15
years to write this book?
And I guess there are
another couple of things
that we like about it.
We think they're
pretty interesting.
pretty practical.
We have a lot of-- we've done
a set of field experiments
with companies.
And the results have
been pretty rewarding.
But the main thing is we
live in a complex world.
And, again, you all be very
familiar with the notion
of complexity.
Neil and I-- this is my
colleague Neil Thompson,
by the way.
Neil and I, our offices
is right over there.
And we have a lot of
colleagues who are
interested in systems dynamics.
And the definition of
complexity that they
bring to bear to technical
systems or social systems
is multiple units
interacting with one another
rather than being
Brownian motion
of gas molecules
interacting with one another
where there's dynamism
to those interactions.
So they, actually,
we have colleagues
who measure with some precision
the level of complexity
in a system.
So that's the defining
characteristic.
And most of the world we
live in is just complex.
That's most of the
things we're trying
to achieve whether it's dealing
with terrorism or eradicating
disease.
The desired result
comes out of a lot
of interactions of a
lot of moving parts
that are changing over time.
So complexity is a fundamental
issue that we grapple with.
And the tendency is
often to say, oh look,
we've got a complex problem.
We've got a complex system.
We need a complex
solution to manage it.
We need a complex interface
to manage complexity.
We call it the myth of
requisite complexity--
the assumption that
complex problems
require complex solutions.
And the argument that
we make in this book
is that's not
necessarily true that it
is possible and
empirically, theoretically,
practically
demonstrably possible
in certain circumstances
to manage complex systems
and address complex problems
with a simple interface.
So the kind of analog is
to these simple interfaces
for consumer products.
And what we're not
arguing, by the way,
is simple is always
better than more complex.
We are not arguing that.
OK?
We're very careful in the
book to talk about boundary
conditions--
circumstances under which
simple rules or some other
simple approach would be good.
And then there are clearly cases
where more complex approaches
are more appropriate.
So for instance,
no one wants to be
the person who lives next
to a nuclear reactor run
on simple rules.
You just don't.
You don't want a doctor who
uses simple rules rather
than a surgical checklist.
There are domains where
alternatives are clearly
superior to simple rules.
So we're not saying simple
rules are always better.
But what we are
saying is complexity
is not always better.
It's not always necessary.
And it's not always better.
Now, I'll give you an example.
So I'll ask this
question first of all.
Does anybody recognize
that equation?
I just gave this speech in
Stockholm to a bunch of CEOs
and, surprisingly, one of
the women raised her hand
and she said, oh,
yeah, of course,
that's the Markowitz
efficiency frontier.
I was like, hold on a second.
How did you know that?
And it turns out she had written
her PhD on this guy Harry
Markowitz.
So now I always ask.
It makes it kind of fun.
So this is an equation
written by a guy named
Harry Markowitz to address
on of the fundamental issues
in finance, which is how
you allocate your asset
across various asset classes.
And Harry Markowitz won
the Nobel Prize for this.
It's basically a
model that helps
you to think about a frontier
where you're constantly trading
off risk and reward and where
the optimal point would be
or where the trade
offs would be.
And it's fairly
computationally intensive.
You need a lot of
data the calculate it
as the number of
asset class increases.
And then an alternative
way to allocate assets
is this-- 1 over N, which is
about the dumbest, simple rule.
If you could count, your dog
could probably more or less
do that one.
It's a pretty simple rule.
And I think most
people would assume
that when it came to
allocating their assets,
this would be superior.
It's a more sophisticated model.
The guy won a Nobel Prize.
This is a really stupid,
simple rule-- really dumb,
simple rule.
And yet, there were
some colleagues
who are financial
economists did a horse
race between the 1 over
N rule and the Markowitz
rule on some derivatives
of the Markowitz rule
across 28 real-world data sets.
The results?
1 over N won 80% of the time.
1 over N essentially never
lost investors' money.
The Markowitz and its
derivative equations
lost investors' money
about 40% of the time.
I hasten to add this is before
accounting for the fees that
are normally associated for
these more sophisticated
investment equations.
So, again, we're not
saying complexes--
we're not saying simple is
always better than the complex.
You don't want to
be-- in the old days,
people used to guess
the weather by red sky
at night, sailor's delight.
That's a case where you
don't want a simple rule.
You want the Weather Channel.
There are certainly domains
where more sophisticated
algorithms and equations
are more appropriate.
But it is not necessarily
inherently the case
that complex models are
always better than simple ones
because there are
a bunch of reasons.
The deepest one is the
bias/variance trade off.
You can over-fit data and if
you don't understand causality,
you get into trouble.
So what do simple rules do well?
And, again, in the book,
we're super-careful not
to argue that no matter
what your problem is,
simple rules is a solution
because anybody who does this,
anybody who does this
says here is my book,
and no matter your problem,
this is the answer is
one of three things.
They are lying, they are
delusional, or they are both.
There's just no
one-size-fits-all, right?
So in the book, we talk
through in some detail
the boundary
conditions under which
simple rules are a
sensible approach
and when they're inappropriate.
So what I'd like to do is talk
through five applications where
simple rules-- where we
have evidence that they work
consistently well that
are also potentially
interesting and
relevant to you guys.
The first one is
coordinate on the fly.
So allow a complex
adaptive system
to self-organize and
coordinate activities
without some kind of
superseding direction.
For centuries it was a
mystery how birds flocked.
And I'll just give
you just a fixed why--
what the mystery was.
I'll show you a short video.
So phenomenal behavior.
And literally, for
centuries, no one
had been able to explain how
birds were able to coordinate
their activity in
flight until along comes
a guy named Edmund Selous.
Has anybody ever heard
of Edmund Selous?
A bit of an obscure figure.
But he is a very
credible pioneer
in the field of ethology.
Ethology is the field that
studies social animals, insects
in the wild-- and one of two
or three pioneers of this.
And in 1901, one he decides to
begin a research project to,
once and for all, explain the
flocking behavior of birds.
He spends not 10
years, not 20 years,
but 30 years in the field
carefully observing,
carefully plotting the behavior,
testing rival alternative
hypotheses to understand
how birds flock.
In 1931, he makes presentation
to the Royal Academy of Science
in the UK, of which
he is a member,
to present this findings.
And people are quite curious.
This is a big deal question.
Nobody had really
understood the answer.
So Selous gets up and he says,
I've been out in the field
30 years.
I've carefully plotted things.
I've eliminated all the
things we thought it might be.
There's clearly no
director or kind
of orchestrating everything.
Nope, it's not that.
They are not
coordinating by sound.
They're not coordinating
by-- it's not
a function of prevailing winds.
He goes through one by one.
Folks are like,
OK, they're sitting
on the edge of their seat.
What is the answer?
He says, I think by almost
process of elimination,
I figured out how these birds
coordinate their activities.
He says, what it is-- it's
avian telepathy-- thought
transference.
So your reaction was
the approximate reaction
of his colleagues at the
Royal Academy of Science.
It's like chuckle, chuckle,
slight bemusement .
Maybe Edmund spent a bit
too much time in the field.
There's eccentric, and
then there's eccentric.
And yet the challenge--
and by the way,
it was a beautifully
titled book.
It may be the favorite title
of a book I've ever seen.
It was called "Thought
Transference (Or What?)
in Birds."
And so it was
basically like, I know
it seems a little flaky,
thought transference,
I don't know what
else it could be.
And essentially for 50 years
or what was the state of play?
Nobody could explain it
until the answer emerged out
of an unlikely place, unlikely
from the position of biologists
at least-- a computer
lab here at MIT
where a guy named Craig Reynolds
who was studying computer
animation was playing around
and trying to figure out how
to simulate birds in flight.
And he used an approach,
agent-based modeling,
which I'm sure a lot of you are
very familiar with where he had
these separate agents,
and he programmed them
with simple rules.
And through some
trial and error,
he came up with
three simple rules
that he programmed into
what he called boids.
And these are basically just
head in the same direction,
stick close together, and don't
bump into stuff-- very simple.
And this is what those rules
produce just to give you
a sense of how it works.
So what's interesting is
now in social biology,
simple rules are all
the rage in terms
of modeling complex
behavior in social systems.
Craig went on to win the Academy
Award for his contribution
to computer animation.
So it was quite--
AUDIENCE: I think a
SIGGRAPH award too.
DONALD SULL: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I think
a SIGGRAPH award.
DONALD SULL: Oh, yeah, yeah.
He's been super-influential
with this approach.
And by the way, this
isn't just animal systems.
I assume many of you have
used, at some point, Zipcar.
If you think about Zipcar,
it's a similar thing.
It's not Hertz or Avis where you
pull the car and somebody makes
sure it's clean-- somebody
makes sure it's full of fuel.
There's someone
coordinating all this.
You rely on members
who have never met each
and never will meet each other.
And when Robin Chase and her
co-founders founded Zipcar,
one of things they
could have done
to try to allow these
members to self-organize
is create some
big, thick contract
that nobody would read
or pay attention to.
What they did instead
was they came up
with a set of simple rules.
They covered the
most common sources
of conflict between
users, but were also
small enough in number
and simple enough
to remember that people actually
remembered them and followed
them-- pets in containers,
and fill her up
that eliminated the vast
majority of conflicts
between members.
So we see this is a
very interesting domain.
We see in a lot of
virtual communities,
simple rules emerging
to help members
coordinate their activities.
Another thing, translate
big data into action.
So I sit on the
committee at MIT that's
proposing a new masters
in data analytics.
And, touch wood, that's
going to come out next year.
And it's really our
colleagues there
know a lot about how to collect
data, how to structure it,
how to frame a problem,
model a problem,
how to write the algorithms.
I think one area that we've all
recognized we know a little bit
less about is how get-- how
you manage the algorithm/human
hand off-- how you get people to
use the insights from big data.
Obviously, if you
Google, you just
program it into the computer,
and that's a trivial issue.
But if you need
human beings to use
the algorithms and the
insights from data analytics,
that's something we know
a little bit less about.
And so we've seen
this problem before.
How many of you have seen
"Moneyball," just out
of idle curiosity?
So we all think we know the
story of "Moneyball," which
is the following for both of
you who didn't see the film
or didn't raise your hand.
Oakland A's lose
three all stars.
They have a budget
of roughly a third
of the richest
teams in the league.
And the opportunity set of
potential replacements numbers
in the tens of thousands.
So this is a very
daunting choice problem.
And, historically, this
is they're player budget.
Historically, these
decisions have
been made by scouts, people who
have to played baseball often,
have not finished high school
or college, devoted their lives
to baseball.
Question?
How many of these fellows do you
think have a PhD in statistics?
It's just not their background.
They have other advantages.
They know the game.
They've spent a lot of
time seeing players.
But they know the game.
So Billy Beane, as we all know,
brings in the statistician,
who is going to do sophisticated
analysis to identify arbitrage
opportunities in the
baseball labor market.
So that's the story.
And I think a lot of
people left the cinema
thinking this is the future?
Sabermetrics?
And these guys are dinosaurs--
destined for extinction.
I think that was the
impression a lot of us
left the cinema with.
That's not true.
It turns out the Oakland A's
have actually not decreased
spending on scouts.
They've increased
And the way Billy Beane
and the team have framed
the question is not algorithm
versus scouts, which is better?
It's how can we combine the
benefits of both approaches
to make better decisions?
And the way they did it
is described in the book,
not in the film, is
through simple rules.
So, basically, based on
an analytical approach
of past data, the team
distilled a set of simple rules
like don't go after
players we can't afford.
Don't go after players who have
a substance abuse problem--
no high school players--
that created some boundaries
based on empirical analysis
within which the scouts could
exercise their judgment and
utilize the specific knowledge
they gained through
being on the road.
The fourth rule is
performance trumps promise.
And, again, I stress this.
It's not an algorithm.
You didn't punch the data
in, crank the handle,
and the answer comes out.
Rather, it was a way to
frame the discussion when
they were looking at players.
This is, I think, a really
interesting application
of simple rules
is getting people
to use the insights
from data analytics.
There was a study done by a
colleague of ours, Antoinette
Shore, at MIT, which took
1,200 micro entrepreneurs
in the Dominican Republic and
broke them into three groups.
One group learned accounting
the way it's traditionally
taught as a complex system
of a large set of rules.
The second group learned it
as a set of very simple rules
like have two different
drawers for cash,
one for your personal account,
one for business account-- one
you transfer, write an
IOU-- very simple rules.
And the third was a control.
What they found
was-- and then they
trained the two treatment
groups in the two
different approaches.
What they found
was the following.
The entrepreneurs who
learned accounting
as a set of simple rules
had a 30% percent increase
in revenues, saved more money,
and did better bookkeeping.
What do you think happened to
the entrepreneurs that learned
accounting the traditional way?
Indistinguishable from
the control group.
Let's put it that way,
essentially no impact,
so a very interesting
approach to get
people to use the benefits
of insights from analytics.
Number three, discipline
innovation-- one
of the most common pieces
of advice in the innovation
literature is think
outside the box.
And the underlying
assumption here
is that constraint is the enemy
of creativity or innovation.
Right?
And so you want to
break all constraint.
But, really, if
you think about it,
unconstrained creativity or
innovation is really difficult,
maybe impossible because
your face, if you
have no constraints,
you're faced
with an almost infinite
number of opportunities
which overwhelms people, one.
Two, you ignore
lessons about what
works in creative processes
like agile programming, or XP,
and other things that we
know are more effective.
And three, to the extent
you need different people
to cooperate, to
innovate, if everybody's
going in their own
direction because there are
no constraints, you have chaos.
So unconstrained
innovation-- the assumption
that constraint is bad for
innovation is not good.
And the advice that results
is pretty poor advice.
So an alternative is
rather than saying
how do we think outside the box,
to frame the question is how do
we draw the right
box within which
we pursue some creative
or innovative activity.
And, again, simple
rules are one approach
for self-imposing constraints.
And, again, this is something
we had no idea about when
we started this.
But this is very common
in the creative arts
so that authors or
painters or artists
will draw some set of rules
which will simulate and channel
their creativity.
So Tina Fey, for instance, which
was on "Saturday Night Live"
observed how Lorne
Michaels produced the show.
From that, she
derived a set of rules
she when she was
producing "30 Rock."
And these include
rules like never
tell a crazy person he's crazy,
which actually, the point
being that oftentimes the most
creative people are somewhat
idiosyncratic, and you
need to manage that rather
than-- another one was to
take Harvard lampoon nerds
and stand up comedians,
combine, and mix.
And, again, the idea being
this more cerebral humor
will take you into
doctoral dissertations.
If you just had
stand up comedians,
they'd make a lot of jokes
about bodily functions.
But if you can combine them
and kind of keep that together,
you get much better comedy.
So this is in the
creative domains.
It's quite a common approach.
It's also, I think,
we see it being used
in the corporate world as well.
So Under Armour, I'm
sure, most of you
are familiar with a pretty
new company-- $3 billion
in revenues.
The brand is quite strong.
And one of the things
they do is every year
they have something called a
future show where they have
an open call to
entrepreneurs and inventors
to present ideas for
innovations to Under Armour.
And they get thousands
of possible innovations.
How do they sift through them?
How do they prioritize?
And how do they choose?
It turns out they
use simple rules.
And just to give
you a sense, again,
of some of the concreteness.
So in 2014, the rules they
used were incorporate apps
in wearable technology.
That was a big push for them.
Integrate with Map My Fitness,
which they had acquired in 2013
so that mattered.
When producing data, emphasize
inspiration and insight, not
just information.
That's not of much
help to people.
And make it social
rather than individual
when you're producing
your product.
So, again, these provided a
framework for the discussion
for the evaluation that
allowed them to sort through
very quickly.
A fourth category is
around triaging, allocating
scarce resources.
So the triage is one of the
earliest modern approaches
that we see of widespread,
simple rule use.
So triage comes from
the domain of medicine.
Actually, the
person who invented
this use of simple
rules, or pioneered
the use of simple
rules, was a guy
named Larrey, who was the
surgeon general for Napoleon's
Grand Army.
And it was to allocate--
the situation problem is
after a battle, you have a
large stack of injured soldiers.
And you have limited doctors,
medicines, beds, and so forth.
How do you allocate
those scarce resources?
And you have to do
it very quickly.
And so the approach
that Larrey pioneered
was you use a small set of
simple rules, check the pulse,
check responsiveness,
breath rate,
to quickly categorized
patients into one
of a couple categories.
So one category is you're going
to fine no matter what we do.
We give you some aspirin
and put you in the corner.
The second categories
is, alas, there's
nothing we can do to save you.
We give you some
stronger painkiller,
and put you in the corner, which
parenthetically if you're ever
in the emergency room,
they give you some pills,
and put you in the corner,
it could be good news.
It could be very bad news.
And then the third
category is those people
who can be saved, but
only with intervention.
And based on this quick
assessment with simple rules,
they are the ones who
receive the resources.
This is a very useful approach
to allocating scarce resources.
I work now with the
Gates Foundation.
And people think of
the Gates Foundation
as they have a lot of money.
The Gates Foundation
gives more in a year
than the next hop-- than
the next 10 largest US
philanthropies combined.
So they have a large endowment,
and they do give lot of money.
But when you compare it to
the scope of their ambition,
it's actually pretty a
small amount of money.
So in the global
health bit, which
is just one of three major
divisions in the Gates
Foundation, their
ambition is to eradicate
childhood mortality in poor
countries around the world.
That's an audacious goal.
And against that goal, the
resources they bring to bear
are pretty scarce.
So they use a set
of simple rules
to guide-- to provide a
framework for these decisions.
So one is that they look
at the disability adjusted
life years, which basically
says for every disease
when do patients
typically contract it,
and how many years of
life do they lose to death
or disability, and
aggregate those up,
which gives-- it's a crude
proxy, but a useful mechanism
for comparing across diseases.
They only focus on poor-- the
poorest countries in the world.
Rich country diseases
like childhood obesity,
for instance, is not
their focus-- very focused
on technology rather than
structural or institutional
changes.
So vaccines are
a great approach.
And if somebody else is
working on the problem,
they typically will
let them do that.
They'll focus in the gap.
So they use these
simple rules to allocate
their scarce resource.
And these are hard choices.
Bear in mind, for
what they're doing,
literally any disease
category that they
choose to deprioritize,
children die by the nation.
These are very hard decisions
that they're faced with,
and these rules can help
to make those decisions.
And then the final
category of applications
is embed strategy
where it matters most.
So Neil and I both
teach strategy at MIT.
A lot of companies
have a strategy,
and it's sitting on a
shelf gathering dust.
That's not a strategy.
That's a book report.
The question in a
lot of organizations
is how do you embed the
insights of a strategy, which
is essentially a
hypothesis about a
how a firm will
create and capture
economic value in the decisions
that matter most on a day
to day basis in
the organization.
And, again, one mechanism,
not the only mechanism,
but one mechanism
is simple rules.
And I'll give you
a quick example.
Are you folks familiar with 3G?
The private equity firm?
They've bought Heinz,
Kraft, InBev, Burger
King, Tim Hortons.
They are very active, very
successful private equity firm.
And the head of--
the chairman of 3G
is a guy named Alex Behring.
Shortly after he graduated
from business school,
one of his first
jobs was to take over
a newly privatized leg of
the Brazilian freight railway
system.
And to say it was a mess does
a disservice to the term mess.
It was a disaster.
Basically, crops were
rotting in the field
because they had
lack of capacity.
Soybeans were
rotting in the field.
20% of the bridges were
on the verge of collapse.
They were literally
using steam engines.
They had engines that you
put wood in, light the wood.
This is in the mid 1990s.
They had a huge medical
expense because there
were poisonous snakes in the
grass around the yards that
kept biting the employees.
So it was really
a tough situation.
And you can imagine somebody--
a young guy coming in--
and he's got to deal
with all these problems.
It could be a
little overwhelming.
So what Alex did was
he used simple rules.
And I'll just walk
you through this
very quickly, the
steps, because these
are the steps we
argue are or more
generally helpful when you're
developing simple rules
to embed strategy.
So the first thing is
you get some clarity
on what will move the needle.
In strategy, our
focus is on how you
increase customers' willingness
to pay or cut costs.
And there are a
million-- and you
want to maximize the
gap between those two.
There are literally
countless things
you can do that make
the needles twitch,
but in most
organizations, relatively
few actions that will
lead to a material
increase and willingness to
pay-- material decrease in cost
and be sustained over time.
So the first step
is getting clarity
on what those things will be.
And, in their case, it
doesn't have to be tricky.
It was, for instance, rather
than pursuing new business,
increasing revenues
with existing customers
or cutting costs.
These were not-- this
wasn't tricky stuff.
The second step then,
having clarified
what will move the needles
for your organization
is to identify a
bottleneck, which
we define as a specific
activity or decision that
will significantly impact your
ability to move the needles.
And in most
organizations, there will
be many candidates for
this, but it actually
is a pretty straightforward
process or pretty quick process
to focus in on one.
In that case, it
was pretty easy.
They had about $200
million worth of requests
for a proposal because of
the systemic underinvestment
in the railway.
And they only had about
$15 million in cash.
So that was a clear bottleneck.
And then you develop
the simple rules.
And, again, these
weren't tricky rules.
It was around minimizing
upfront expenditure,
removing obstacles
to growing revenues
with current customers.
So if you came in
with the proposal,
one of the first
questions you get
is how will this help us to
keep the soybeans from rotting
on the fields?
And if you didn't have
an answer to that,
the odds were not high
that you'd get funding.
If you had an answer
to that, the odds
were pretty high
you'd get funding.
And so they'd develop and
test the simple rules.
And what's interesting--
one of the things that's
interesting about this is
as organizations get larger,
and I guess Google these days
is a pretty large organization,
it's hard for people
throughout the organization
to understand really
what the strategy is.
It's easier when it's
a small organization.
People are geographically
co-located.
This mechanism not only helps
you to make better decisions
quickly, but also helps for
people on the front line
to understand what
you're trying to do.
So an interesting little
anecdote out of this.
So they're going
around communicating
the strategy, the bottleneck
they're focusing in
on the rules to employees.
And one of the employees-- he
works basically in the gasoline
station, in the petrol
station, filling the trains
when they pull in.
He raised his hand.
He says, listen,
what you're saying
is you don't want the
crops rotting on the field?
They're like, yep, that's right.
He said, you want
us to do it cheap?
He said, yeah, that's
what we're trying to do.
And he says, if that's
what we're doing,
I never really knew that's
what we're trying to do.
But I've got an idea.
He said, look, it takes a
lot of time for these trains
to pull in and get fuel.
They have to come
off the tracks.
They often have to wait.
They have to wait their turn.
Then they go out.
We lose a lot of
time that we could be
moving freight because of this.
He said, what about
if we just doubled
the size of the fuel tank?
That one idea, one
suggestion, that
only emerged because
for the first time,
this employee understood
what they were trying to do,
saved them something
like 1% of EBITDA
in the first year,
which is a lot of money
for a business like that.
So it can have
some real benefits.
And we see consistently
that organizations
that do this-- they can get
pretty good results pretty
quickly.
In the ALL case they
basically tripled their EBITDA
in the span of
about three years.
There were obviously other
things they were doing.
But these simple
rules played a role.
And I'll just conclude by
noting the six types of rules,
and then I'll shut up
and open it up to Q&A.
So one of the things that was
interesting to us, we've again,
studied simple rules across
many different domains,
many different sets
of simple rules.
One of the things
that was interesting
is out of that emerged
a set of six categories
that the rules fall
into, and I'll just
introduce those to you.
So the first three are--
we kind of lumped together
as decision rules.
So one is boundary rules--
what's inside and outside.
So think of the Billy
Beane, no high school
players, no players with
salaries we can't pay.
Stay outside the boundaries,
and then you exercise judgment
within those boundaries.
The second set of rules
are around prioritizing
alternatives, allocating
scarce resources
to competing uses like the
Gates Foundation rules.
A third set of rules
is stopping rules.
So it turns out it is
very well documented
that individuals,
teams, organizations,
have a tendency to persist
in lines of activity
beyond the optimal point.
They want to save face.
There is some cost fallacy.
There are a variety of social
and psychological factors
that lead to that tendency.
And we see simple rules
often used, for instance,
in investment as
to rules to when
you kill an investment there.
It's a common application.
And then the bottom three
are a little bit less
about what to do and
about how to do it.
So the how-to rules--
those provide some guidance
on a process like
Tina Fey's producing
"30 Rock" or the simple
rules of bouncing.
Timing rules link the
timing of an activity
to typically external events.
So there's a large
Brazilian conglomerate.
And it has been
extremely successful
over the past 100 years.
And they have a set of
rules that they use.
They are very asset-
intensive businesses
that they use to buy and
sell their businesses.
And most of the rules are around
boundary and prioritization.
But I asked them when
I was down there,
do you have any time rules?
And they said sheepishly
they look at each other
and should we tell him?
Yeah, we'll tell him.
Yeah, we have a timing rule that
has worked pretty well for us.
And I said, what's that?
They said, well, we buy
when the gringos are selling
and sell when the
gringos are buying.
And it turns out
it's actually, when
you think about it,
a pretty good role
because when the Europeans
and the North Americans
are coming down in hoards,
they are throwing money
at bad assets, and
when they're panicking,
they're often leaving
good assets in their wake.
And then the final
category is coordination
like the Zipcar rules
or the bird rules
that we talked about.
OK, so I'll pause
it there and see
if there are any questions
or comments or anything
you'd like to discuss.
Yeah?
Please.
AUDIENCE: You had a picture
of the Google founders.
You kind of quickly skipped it.
DONALD SULL: Oh, yeah, yeah.
I skipped over it only
because I realized you
guys, of all people,
would note this.
This is actually--
the reason is these
are the rules used
by an incubator that
did not incubate Google.
So I just thought it was an
inappropriate combination
of picture and rules.
This is a firm
called Onset Venture.
So yeah, that was
the rationale for it.
Yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: Do you have simple
rules for a software project?
DONALD SULL: I don't.
But it would certainly be a
domain that would lend itself
to the approach.
If it would be
helpful, I can talk
through just a little bit
other kinds of projects
that we've seen that
might be analogous.
So the basic notion
is to, first of all,
get clarity on what
will move the needles.
And a lot of times that's
what we see, especially
in large, complex organizations
where it requires where there
are interdependencies
between different divisions,
the engineering and
finance and marketing,
whatever it is,
that a lot of times
there is not a shared
set of objectives.
So getting clarity on who's
involved, again, that clear.
Then the second thing is
identifying a bottleneck.
There's a lot of software
programming, new product
development, talent management.
These are broad processes
composed of many steps.
And if you try to come
up with simple rules that
encompass all those steps,
they become too broad.
So it's really helpful to
identify specific activity
within that chain of events
to focus in on the rules.
And then the other thing,
which I think for Google,
would be so obvious.
But one is data trumps opinion.
So a lot of times people--
I have an opinion,
I have an opinion.
No.
We're ruthless about testing.
How do you know if rules
work unless you have clarity
and what your dependent variable
is, you have some comparison
state beforehand or
ideally a control,
and then you do
the intervention,
and you measure it?
So data trumps opinion.
And you can look at historical
data, comparative case study,
large sample data, also
that the users make
the rules, and especially
in complex processes
in organizations where multiple
units need to coordinate
for the activity to work well.
That would entail, not
just the engineers,
but if it's marketing or quality
control, whoever it would be,
to get them involved
in the process as well.
So is that helpful?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DONALD SULL: Yeah?
Please.
AUDIENCE: There's the comparison
of simple rules versus no rules
or complex rules.
Did you run across cases
where an organization
tested one set of simple
rules against another set
of simple rules?
Or how did they
determine whether they
have the right rules?
DONALD SULL: Yes, it's
a very small sample.
And, actually, one of things
Neil and I are very keen to do
is we're going to start
a course on A/B testing
of organizational interventions
at MIT because that's exactly
the right question.
So we have had-- so what I
did basically for four years
was work with an organization
called the Young Presidents'
Organization, which has
founders or CEOs who
have run a materially
sized organization
before the age of 40.
And we'd have cohorts
of 10 to 12 come in,
and we'd do a simple
rules intervention
and then measure the impact
of those interventions.
And there were a couple of
cases where people actually
tried a different set of rules.
So I'll just give you
one concrete example.
There's a company
called Frontier Dental.
They make dental implants.
And the problem
they have, there's
about 200,000 dentists
in North America.
They had a sales force of 12.
And it typically
would take 200 calls
before you'd make a sale
because dentists make money
with patients in chairs,
not talking to sales people.
So the bottleneck
they focused in on
was the prioritization of
the dentist to focus in on.
And what they did was they
took a subset of their database
and divided it into three
with some dentists who
were good customers,
some not so good,
and a bunch in the
middle, and assigned those
to three separate teams
of users, each of whom
based independently,
inferred a set of rules,
then they tested those
rules, and then they
converged on what worked best.
But yeah, what it requires--
what's interesting
is it requires a commitment
to the scientific method
on the part of companies.
I find it shocking
personally that people
try all sorts of
stuff in organizations
and never once do a trial, never
once say is it going to work?
No, let's just roll it out.
It seems insane when
you think about it.
And, yet, we found in
talking to companies
not every company
is keen on the idea
of-- what the response is, oh,
we're sure it's going to work.
Let's give it to everybody.
Why would we have
a control group?
No, you're missing the point.
So it's exactly the right
idea, but sometimes hard to get
organizations to buy into it.
Yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: How about
exceptions to the rules?
I was intrigued by
the A's example.
I'm a baseball fan.
But the draft was last week,
and they took a few high school
guys.
DONALD SULL: Yeah, sure,
so I would code that,
in that specific case, less
about exceptions to rules,
and more about rules evolving.
So we talk about exactly
this in the book.
So if you're in a
non-competitive situation,
your rules might stay stable
for a long period of time.
The Gates Foundation
doesn't have
competitors trying to thwart
them in curing these diseases.
The A's do.
You have people
poaching their players
and trying to figure out
what their rules are.
And so in those domains where
people will come in and emulate
your rules and
therefore decrease,
in that case, the
arbitrage opportunities,
they were forced to evolve
their rules over time.
So that was more of a case
of evolution than exception.
By and large if
you've done a good job
of basing the rules on
data and testing them
before you roll them
out and striking
the right balance of
guidance and discretion,
you would want the exceptions
to be pretty minimal, which
by the way, it's so important
to have the users make
the rules because they
are the ones best situated
to assess whether you've struck
the right balance of guidance
and discretion.
Yeah?
Please.
AUDIENCE: Presumably
in your studies
you've come across cases where
simple rules would be useful.
But they're not
there [INAUDIBLE].
Do you find that it's
more often a lack of rules
or overly complicated rules?
DONALD SULL: It totally depends
on the size the organization.
So, for start ups,
what we typically find
is that it will be a lack
of rules, by and large.
For large, complex
organizations over time,
they accrue huge rule sets
through a cumulative process.
So the way we think
about this is imagine
a spectrum of absolutely no
constraint, just pure chaos,
everybody does what they
want, to perfect constraint
where every possible contingency
is identified ex ante,
and you specify
precisely what to do.
And so what we
find, big companies
are moving from this way
to that direction and start
ups are moving that direction.
And our argument is that there
is a privilege spot, or a very
interesting spot, on this
spectrum where you introduce
a threshold level of structure
that avoids the cost of chaos
without imposing a lot
of the cost of rigidity
that accrue as you go
farther on the spectrum.
Yeah?
Please.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like
often simple rules come
in the domain of organizations.
But then there is the personal.
Like, for example, parenting.
And it seems that folks
out there, they [INAUDIBLE]
simple rules for parents.
But over time you would
think that wouldn't
be simple rules be established?
Like there is one
way for parenting.
And these are the simple
rules for parenting.
Why is that not the case?
DONALD SULL: So it's
a fantastic question.
We have a point of view on this.
Our big argument
is that there is--
rules are context-specific.
They are specific
to, in that case,
the family, the
individual parents,
the culture in which
you are embedded,
the time, all those things.
So we are really not big
fans of universal rules
you take off the shelf.
Here are the three
rules of parenting
or five rules of
parenting it's not
to say they are good
sources of inspiration.
And they're not well-intended.
I'm sure they're
both of those things.
But the argument, we feel
very passionately about this,
is you need to develop the
rules that work for you.
And we actually have
a chapter in the book
called "Getting Personal,"
which talks about this process.
And if it's helpful, I'll
just give you a quick example
to illustrate.
So in the middle of
writing this thing,
it was the depth of
the Boston winter,
and I just, the Michelin Man
came and delivered a tire
to my stomach.
And simultaneously, I just
ordered a bunch of shirts,
and the shirts didn't fit, and
I was super-frustrated by this.
And I called the guy, I said,
can I send the shirts back?
He said, no, you can't
send the shirts back.
All right, I'm going
to lose 15 pounds.
This was my goal so I could
fit in these bloody shirts.
And so there are no end of
books out there, diet books.
These are your five rules.
But our approach is to
say, no, first of all,
develop the rules
are right for you.
So first of all, what will
move the needle for you.
It was pretty
straightforward in my case.
I wanted to lose the 15 pounds.
The second point is
identify a bottleneck.
And the more the
specific, the better.
So what I did for
a week was I got
one of these fitness trackers.
I just tracked what
I ate, and exercised.
And what I discovered
very interestingly was
during the day it was OK.
I ate OK.
After dinner, all
hell broke loose.
It was like, oh, the
Merlot, and then there's
the Ben and Jerry's, and then
how about a Snickers bar?
That sounds great.
And so the bottleneck,
in that case,
was after-dinner
snacking, which is good
because I didn't
have to then deploy
limited willpower across
all food decisions
over the course of the day.
It was more narrow.
And the third thing
is develop rules that
worked in my specific context.
And these aren't-- you
don't just make them up.
I looked at the research.
And for instance, there's a guy
named Brian Wansink at Cornell,
who has done a lot of really
neat work about portion control
as the key driver
of caloric intake.
So I had a rule like eat
chips out of a bowl, not a bag
because you frame how
much you should eat based
on the size of the container.
Another was around
no stockpiling.
So if you have a
box of Snickers,
you eat a box a Snickers.
If you have only one Snicker,
you can only eat one Snicker.
And then, again,
of course, testing.
And in this case, it's
pretty straightforward.
You test can you-- what
happens with change in weight?
So we would argue,
and we actually
talk about some
cases in the book,
of in a family domain, how
you would develop rules
that are right for your family.
And, by the way,
it worked for me.
This is one of the shirts.
So I'm really happy.
It was like a good use of
simple rules for me at least.
Great.
OK, so I apologize.
I think we've run out of time.
But I hope it was of
some interest to you all.
And thanks for the opportunity
to come and chat with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]